あの十二の あの アンガですか
部分という あの 一つ一つ説明やりました
で まあそれについてまあいろいろ説明
それからほんのちょっと入りますけど
あの頁のあの五番目書いてるところ
このアッダアディリバーガ
で まあ三字などの分別数ですね
アッダっていうのはまあ時間のことで
あ 時間のことで三つありますと
あの それから部分として見ると十二がありますと
ブッダサンガーニヴィーサティアーカル
それからこの二重行層という
あの まあ方法 三つ 二重に分けて方法として説明してるんですね
それからまあサンディジョイントは四つありますという
あの まあ一応項目なんですけど
一応あの説明しているとわかると思います
まずこの あの時間として
過去現在未来に十二因縁を分けているんです
まず十二因縁を書いておかないと
一応この十二ですね 番目はヴィッジャ無明で
番目はサンカーラ行で
番目はヴィンヤーナ識で
番目はナーマループ名色で
番目はロクショサラエダ
で 番目はソク発想ですね
で 番目はベーベナ受ですね
感覚 で それから番目はタンハー渇愛で
で 番目はオパーダな固執ですね
執着ですね それからプーと書いてますからね
ババ それからショウ 生まれること
それから老死ですね それはまあ一応十二因縁の簡単な部分なんです
で 項目一つ一つの説明は
まあいくらか簡単に説明して終わりましたので
あの 今日繰り返してやる必要はないと思います
でもあの こういうあの十二のこの説明っていうのは
これもうかなりたくさん
何回何回何回も あの 聞いておかないと
まあ理解できないと思いますけど
理解するためには やっぱり自分で物事を考えるということはどうしても必要し
あの なかなか自分で考えようとは
あの 人間の心っていうのはしないんだからね
そこでわからないだけのことなんですね
まあ誰かから何か言葉を教えてもらって
その基準で考えようとしてるんですね
まあそれで何もわからないんです
ですから この やっぱり自分の問題として自分で考えなくちゃいけないんですね
そう 自分で考えると何か間違ってもこれはこういうことかと聞いてみれば
それは違うんだったら
そこら辺ちょっと違いますよというだけで
それでまた自分で考えてみれば
正しく理解できるようになるんです
それは誰にしたっても同じことで
特に因縁とか因果の法則っていうのは自分で考えるしか方法ないんです
そういうのはなかなか言葉で説明できるものではないし
人が考えて書いてるようなチャートとかいろいろあるんだけど
それに頼る必要も結局はないんです
とにかくアビダンマテキストでは
この因縁というか この十二の支を連続通して
流れ通して 私が使っている言葉っていうのはsequentialという言葉ですからね
順番で考えているんですね
でも順番で考えていても
そこで因縁を説明したことにはならないんですね
順番に考えるということは
まず無明がある 無明から業が生じると
業からヴィンヤーナが
識が生じると ヴィンヤーナからナーマルーパが生じると
ナーマルーパから属が生じると
それはsequentialで順番の考え方なんですね
でも お釈迦様が別にそういう風には説明してないんです
例えばavijjāからサンカーラが生じるという場合は
それは正しいかとないかと見るために逆にも考えなくてはならないんですね
ですからavijjāある時サンカーラがあるんだと avijjā
がなければサンカーラもないんだという風に2つ考えているんですね
だからavijjāが消えたらサンカーラが消えるということは avijjā
とサンカーラの間では何か関係あるということになっちゃうんですね
サンカーラが消えたという途端 avijjā
も消えているんですね
だからお釈迦様がおっしゃっているのは avijjā
とサンカーラの間で厳密な離れない
切れない関係があるということなんです
その関係とか そういう言葉は昔なかったんだから
誤解 今現代誤解している可能性もあります
でも お釈迦様が使っている言葉はpaccayaという言葉なんですね Avijjā
paccaya sankhāra paccaya
このpaccayaという言葉分析すると
それは関係であることはわかるだろうと思いますけど
一応経典文句は覚えていらっしゃると思いますけど avijjā
paccaya sankhāra sankhāra
paccaya viññāṇaというふうに出ていきますから
で なかなか誰もそのパッチアっていう言葉を説明していないんです
で 一人の学者だけ あの現代
あの まああの それ あの哲学者なんですけど
あの まあ亡くなった先生なんですけど
あの もう大変 あの まあ天才的な能力あった人で
まあ知らないものは何かあるかという疑うほど
まあいろんな分野幅広く知っていて
もうヨーロッパの言語といえばもうほとんど知っていて
まあインドの言語も古い言語やら
もう何から何までまあ知り尽くしていたんです
かなり若い先生でも すごい若い時亡くなりましたけどね
その先生はテキストは一つしか書いて出してないんです
あの小さな論文とかはたくさんありますけどね
で    UN の国連とか そういうところでも
何かそういう国際的な問題なんかあったりすると
あの国でも代表としてまあ講演頼んだりもしていましたけど
で そういう特にあの民衆問題に対して
あの昔まあ問題があって
まあそれにこの先生が
まあそれをどう見るべきかという講演して
それはよくかなり広げて講演そのものも発表してあります
で その先生の論文というのはなかなか人は読まないんです
まあすごいあの 読むためにもかなり膨大な知識が必要なんです
決して難しく書いてるわけじゃないんだけど
だからあの一行一行厳密に書いてあって
だから一行 行単位で文
あの番号を振ってるんです
大きな論文ですけどね
これは認識論というテキストで
まあそのテキストの中でその先生
パッチアという言葉の分析するんですね
で それはあの文法だから
ちょっと分かりにくいかもしれませんだけど
このパティックイという
この三つでその言葉が出てくるんです
パティっていうのは この言葉の前に付ける言葉で
これはあのプリフィックスと英語で言うんですね
日本語で何言うかわからない
言葉の前にちょっと一言葉付けちゃうんですね
後ろに付ける言葉には英語で蘇フィックスというんですね
ある単語に前と後ろに何か付けて意味を与える
それは英語でもいくらかありますし
ドイツ語ではもう明確にあるし
フランス語でもありますし
一応あのインド ヨーロッパ
文化 まあ言語系ではよく使うものなんですね
漢字使うとまあそれほどできませんだからもう漢字の世界でも
やっぱり言葉に前に後ろに何か付けて違う単語を作るということはないわけじゃないんです
例えばもう大とか小とか妙とか付けてるでしょうにね
法の言葉の前に妙つけて妙法と言うでしょうし
まあそれはどうせサンスクリット語でありますからね
法はダンマであって サッダンマになっちゃうと妙ということを付けちゃうんですね
妙法 で 例えば大乗というマハヤーナという言葉ありますね
ヤーナという乗り物で偉大なるという乗り物と言うためにマハという言葉を付けた
それはプリフィックスですね
それでそれを日本語訳するときも大ということ
大乗になっちゃうんですね
日本語になっちゃうと大きな乗り物になりますけど
で あの そこでパティとイというのは
あの動く 変化する 行くという意味なんです
行くという意味の動詞なんですね
だから動詞ですから この印でそれ付けちゃうんですね
ルートのルート書くんです
ルートっていうのはこの単語のルートですから
単語はすべて動詞で出来上がってるんです
これは中国語と違うんですね
中国語ではすべて名詞で成り立ってるみたいですが
動詞がないんです で サンスクリット語はすべて動詞で成り立ってるんです
動詞から名詞を作ります
だからパティっていうのは関わりがあるという意味なんです
関わりがあって動くということは変化する
これは名詞になる蘇フィックスです
で この中にまたいくつかの文字を入れなくちゃいけないんだけどね
まあそうするともう厳密に文法的に説明しなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんで
それすごい時間かかるわけです
で とにかくイとアは発音できませんだからね
ヤが必ず入るんです イとアの間はね
ア いわゆるセミボウルというもの
ディフサン セミボウル入ります
それでサンスクリット語と違う
サンスクリット語 パーリ語で巻きまっていて
カ入っちゃうんです キーのない
だからカにヤが入りますから
パティッチーになって
このティはサンスクリット語になる
パーリ語になっちゃうとシシーチャになっちゃうんです
そこでパティッチーになっちゃうんです
これをサンスクリット語で書けば
こうじゃなくてこうなっちゃうんです
プリティなんですね プリティプラスキーのルートとキーのルートでヤーなんですね
で これはティーとアーなんです
これ分析しちゃうとティーとアー
アーはサンスクリット語でアーで書かないでアスと書くんですから
で それはアスの捨てる
これ捨てるとその影響でこちらで変化が起こるんですね
だからこれあることはサンスクリット語を知ってる人は知ってます
この この言葉変化するとどこかなくエスが入ったりします
それどこかなくなって
この一時的に抑えたエスがまた蘇ってきたりとか
そういう風にすごい科学的な分析なんで
サンスクリット語 だから勉強しやすいんです
ものすごく合理的に もう論理的に分析して出来上がっていますから
プリティっていうのは何かな
関わりがあってという意味なんです
だからこれだけ使っちゃうとも関わりがあって
例えば女性という言葉は男性という言葉に関わりがあって生まれるんです
だからサンスクリット語にそれ入れ替えちゃうと
で そのプリティという言葉を入れてね
サンスクリット語で言ったって分かりませんだからね
マヌッシアナプリティという風に言わなくちゃいけないんです
ですから このプリは このプラーとかその難しい発音がパーリ語ではない
サンスクリット語っていうのは人が人間使ってる言葉ではありません
昔から あくまでも人工語なんです
人工語だからすごい合理的なんです
古いんですけど これ紀元前六〇〇もっと前出来上がったんです
いまだにこの文法はもうぎっしりしていて
それほどしっかりした文法はないんです
世の中に 人間使ってる言葉ではいろんな変化が起きますから
論理的に文法はないです
日本語も同じで まあ使っていることはそうなんです
パーリ語っていうのは実際に使っていた言葉なんです
ですから その方言みたいなものですから
難しい発音は全部変えて
プリはパティになります
ティアはチャになります CCA
になっちゃいます そこで何のことなくパティッチという風になりますし
で その これパティッチャの言葉なんです
パッチャエっていうのは同じ言葉なんです
うん  それはブッダの説がまた自分なりにいろんな分析して
それは全部文法的ではないんだけどね
ありまして まあとにかく意味はパッチャエの意味だけ覚えておけば
だけど 関わりがあって起こるという意味じゃなく
関わりがあって変わるということなんです
だから 行くという動くという動詞からできてるんですね
ですからAvijja Pacca SamphadaというのはAvijjaに無明によって行が生じるという意味じゃないんです
意味は無明に厳密ないわゆる不可分
なんで不可分離な関わりが行にあるということなんです
なぜ不可分な関わりがあるかというと
行がなかったらAvijjaも消えてしまうし Avijja
がなかったら行も消えてしまっちゃうんです
一つでもなくなったら全部消えちゃう
この十二もすべてそうやって関わりがあるんです
ですから 一つでもこのセットで消えたら全部セットが消えてしまう
そういうのは世の中の法則としてお釈迦様おっしゃってるわけですね
だから すべてのものは厳密に互いに切り離して不可分離的な関わりを持っているという意味なんです
だから大変 だから故に仏教はPaṭiccasamuppādaに因果法則は仏教の教えなんです
だから仏教教えは特別な宗教的な人間知らないこと
あるいはわざわざと関係ないことを言っているわけではなくて
世の中の真理を語っているんですね
で 問題はこの新しくも
だからすべてのものは厳密にひと塊でお互いに切り離せない
切り離すことできない関わりがあって成り立っているならば
一つの個体になってしまうんでしょうし
で それだけではなくて
もう一つ我々に体験できる問題が世の中にあるんですね
それは物事のシーケンシャル的な変化なんですね
それは目で見たらわかるものなんですね
だから種を植えたら芽が出るとかね
木が出て大きくなってくると
木からまた花が咲くと
花からまた実るというふうな
また順番が順番も見えてるんですね
その人間にそれは分かりやすいんだから
それが因果法則だとすごく勘違いするんですね
そうやって勘違いしたら
いろいろ問題が世の中に生まれるんですね
その場合は原因と結果が離れるんです
切り離すことできるんですね
花から実がなるんだからね
花と実が全く別な存在になっちゃうんです
我々には花を取ってみることもできるし
実を別にとって見ることもできるし
花があって同時に実があるということはありえないんですね
必ずも時間的な隔たりがそこにあるんですね
花取ったら実を取れませんし
実を取ったら花がそこにないし
そちらにはちゃんとしたシーケンシャル的な現象の流れを見えるんですね
ですから この因果法則では
それも合体させなくちゃいけないんです
この不可分離的な 総合的な
相互依存的な関係とシーケンシャル的な
あるいは何と言いますか
シーケンシャルは日本語で何言えばいいんですかね
いわゆる順番として あるいは連続として起こる現象
その両方 シーケンシャルというのは順番
連続ということですけど
連続には英語で違う言葉ありますから
ちゃんと言いますとよね
順番にはまた違う言葉ありますけど
シーケンシャルっていうのは一応
順番で連続的に生まれるっていうことなんですね
で 正しい英語で正しい言葉はとにかくsequentialという正しいこと
だからsequenceという言葉から出てきますからね
miliardiというイベントという出来事という意味なんです
とにかく英語の単語を使っちゃうと
英語で考えなきゃ意味が取れないんです
英語を日本語にしたら
もう全く意味が変わってしまっちゃうんです
この項目のとにかく このテキストでない説明するのは私の仕事だからね
テキスト内説明はご自分で読めるし
で それから私の説明 を理解しておいた方がいいんです
英語でもなかなかないんです
誰も書いてないところたくさんあるんです
そこでアウィッジャーとサンカーラの間では
厳密に互いに関わりがある
だから アウィッジャーとサンカーラが本当は同時存在しているんです
厳密な関わりがあるんだから
同時存在しているようにも見えるし
時間得て考えると別々に見ることもできるんです
とにかくお釈迦様おっしゃった
はっきりと仰った因果法則というのは sequential
よりはこの 何て言いますかね
一つに互いの関わりある
この あれは何て言いますか
アインシュタインの法則は何て言いますか
相対性 この相対性なんですね
お釈迦様が本当は言いたかったのはsequentialのことじゃない
それはもう誰が見たってよくわかることだからね
地震が起きた 家が壊れたと
地震が原因でしょうに
順番があるんです  [物音]だから地震が終わっても結果が残ってるんですね
それ その因果法則っていうのはそれほど大変な発見ではないんです
雨が降らなかった 降らないと乾季になると
そちらにそれほど厳密に発展するべき相対的な相対論がないんですね
わかりやすい わかりやすいんだからそれを取ってるんですけど
お釈迦様がそれを教えているわけじゃないんです
お釈迦様がおっしゃったこととアビダンマで言っていることはまた違うんです
だからそこは僕は今日言いたいところなんです
お釈迦様おっしゃりたかったのは
この相対性 だから無明があるときサンカーラ
行がある 無明がないときは行がない
無明が生まれると行も生まれる
無明が消えると行も消えるという４つのシステムで
その それ確立するんですね
じゃあ そういうわけで
無明と行の間では厳密な関わりがあるということ
だから厳密な関わりがあるという結論を出さないんですね
そこでみんな間違っちゃうんですね
なぜお釈迦様は結論出さないかというと
お釈迦様は言うのは ゆえにアヴィッジャ パッチャー サンカーラだと
だからこの言葉の問題なんですね
だからお釈迦様のこの方程式で言うと
アヴィッジャあるときサンカーラがある
アヴィッジャがないときサンカーラがない
アヴィッジャが現れるときサンカーラも現れる
アヴィッジャが消えるときサンカーラも消える
ゆえにアヴィッジャ パッチャー サンカーラ
だからこのパッチャーという言葉の解釈によって
あるいは翻訳によって問題
ちょっと錯乱してしまっちゃったんですね
パッチャーは何によって生まれると日本訳もしていますからね
無明によって行が生じると
でもパーリ語で一つもないんです
アヴィッジャ パッチャー サンカーラ ウッパジャティ
ウッパジャンティという言葉はないんです
生じるというのはパーリ語に翻訳するとウッパジャンティなんですね
あるいはウッパアジャティでもいいんです
そこはないんです ただアヴィッジャ パッチャー サンカーラ
どうしても動詞入れたければホーティなんですね
アヴィッジャ パッチャー サンカーラ ホーティ
ホーティっていうのは単なる動詞で
まあアヴィッジャによってサンカーラがなりますよということだけ
うん まあそういうことで
だから次にサンカーラとヴィンニャーナの関わりでしょうし
ヴィンニャーナとナーマルーパの関わりがあるでしょうし
ナーマルーパとサラーヤタの関わりがあるでしょうし
そうやってこれ一つも抜けることできないワンセットになっちゃうんですね
私がここで何を言いたいかというと
アヴィッジャからサンカーラが生まれるんだけど
サンカーラがあるときもアヴィッジャもありますということなんです
これでサンカーラからヴィンニャーナが生まれるんだけど
ヴィンニャーナがあるときはサンカーラもあってアヴィッジャもあるということなんです
ということは 生老病死があるときも
これ全部あるんですね
これはもう何か機械に例えてみれば
例えば時計に例えてみれば同じことで
時計のいろんな部品が一つでもなければ時計という風には言えませんね
一つでも取ってしまえば時計が消えてしまうんですね
時計は時計でなくなっちゃうんですね
まあ定義必要ですけど
その場合も 時計というのはちゃんと時間を刻んでくれる
常に働いて一秒一秒動いてくれる機械である
一秒一秒動いてくれるだけではなくて
何時ですかと教えてくれる
時間を教えてくれる また両手で動いている機械です
時計は それだったらこの針一本だけでも取ってしまえば
もう時計でなくなっちゃいますね
時間を教えてくれくれないんだから
中のもういろいろ歯車いろいろありますけど
それ一つでも取ってしまえば
もう時計でなくなっちゃうんです
それでその各部品の仕事なんですかというと
それぞれ自分に別々な仕事があるんですね
例えば時計の文字盤がありますけど
文字盤には別仕事がありまして
ただ文字盤の仕事っていうのは
まあ一応文字を書いているだけであって
まあ針の下にじっと待っていればいいんです
動いちゃったら困るんです
動かないで 文字盤がじっと固定して待ってるんですね
針の仕事は時間を知ることじゃなくて動くだけ
針は動いてくれればいいんです
中の部品にもそれぞれの別々な仕事があるんですね
誰一人もこの時計の中にある部品一人でも時間を教えてあげるという仕事をしているわけじゃないんです
自分に決まってる仕事をしてるだけ
で 最終的に時計という幻覚が生まれるんですね
そういう風に この十二支は時計の部品のようなものなんです
これ一つの人ではないんです
この十人が揃ったところで
人という あるいは生き物という現象
現象でもあるし 幻想でもいいんです
人という現象が成り立つんですね
で 無明は人ではありません
サンカーラは人ではありませんし
どちらでも人ではありません
そこでよく見ると これ私このこの説明
全部このアビダンマでない説明なんです
アビダンマの説明はまああまり学者も認めてないし
私もそれほど正しいとは思ってないし
ですから 一応初期仏教でお釈迦様おっしゃったところをまあ出しておいた方がいいと思って
それからこれ一つ一つものというよりは働きなんですね
例えば分かりやすく ファッサということ
触れるという働きでしょうに
触れるという実体ではないんですね
これ感じるということ
働きでしょうし ヴェーダナ
ジュウは カツアイとの
通りに 渇愛だから 何か働きなんですね
取るということは 執着するということも働きでしょうし
これババウでしょうに
ババっていうのはなるという意味ですからね
それも働きなんですね
これジャーティっていうのは生まれるということだから働きなんですね
じゃあショウロ こっちにはショー入ってない
老病死は何ですかと 老いるっていうことは働きでしょう
病いっていうことは働きでしょう
死ということも働きなんです
ただのファンクション
働きだけなんです いろんな機能の並べなんですね
だから機能だからそちらにも全然実体も何もないんですね
機能の並びだから やっぱり互いに関わりがあって機能しているんです
ですから その説明が悟りに必要であります
我々はこの十二の機能の中で
何か一つ二つ 一つの機能でも
機能しないようにしておけば
そこで他の機能も全部関連性を持ってるんだから
そこで倒れて死ぬことになるんです
で 最後のこのジャラーマラナ見てみましょう
ジャラーマラナっていうのは老いる
これ簡単で 簡単で書いてるだけで
老と死だけ書いてるんですね
老いることと死ぬこと
お経文句ではこれちょっと長いんですね
ジャラーマラナンソーカパリデーワドッカドゥーマナッスウパーヤーサーサンバワンタと書いてますね
全て機能なんですね ジャラマラナ
ジャラは老いること マラナは死ぬこと
ソーカは悲しむこと パリデーは泣くこと
ドゥッカは苦しみ ドゥーマナッスはもう心のなんか暗い状態
落ち込みですね ウパーヤーサーっていうのは
あというふうに このなんかすごい悲しくて
どうしようかというふうに心にある状態ですね
そういうものは生まれるんだと
だからすべて機能でしょ
すべて機能のことなんですね
だから連続性いつでもあります
例えば渇愛がなければ
欲がなければ この生老病死は生まれません
欲がなければ悩むこともないし
どうしようかとかね 泣くこともなくなっちゃうし
だから全部一品につなげているんです
例えば人が誰かが死んだところで大変悲しくなったと
という その場合は なんであなたはそんなに悲しがっていますか？自分にとっては大事な人が死にましたからと
そこでその大事な人が死んだということで
この大事な人に対して執着
欲があったでしょう 欲があったんだから悲しむんであって
別に欲がなかったならば
そこで悲しみが生まれてこないでしょうし
渇愛タンハがなかったならば
ですから 人が死んで泣く時も
そこに その瞬間でもその人に渇愛があるんです
その人の心に渇愛があって
悲しみが生まれて作っているんですね
そしてその人が渇愛を消さなくちゃいけないんですね
だから因縁で言ってるんですね
じゃあ悲しみ消そうと
悲しみ消してもいいんだけど
悲しみ消す場合はやっぱり同時に渇愛も消してもらわなきゃ消せません
お互いにはもう不可分な関係が持ってますから
因縁というのは 因果というのはそのわけで
やっぱり因の方を消さなくちゃいけないんですね
果の方ではなくて だから因と果も両方もう同じ働きであって
全然切り離せない関係なんですね
そこで項目二つ取っちゃえば
取ってみれば前の項目を消すものになっちゃうんです
例えば生 生まれることと
老死で考えちゃえば 現れる
生まれる機能現れたんだから
憎しみ 苦しみ 悲しみが生まれるでしょ
今何か現れたんだから苦しみが生まれる
例えば人が死んだという現象が現れるんですね
それ生なんです そこで悲しみがすぐに生まれてくるんですね
その項目二つだけ取っちゃえば
苦しみなければ生を消さなくちゃいけない